we are trying to make sure that the
government gets its finger out and tries
to fix the economy it's in a poor state
public services and are pretty grim
state investment is is flatlining
productivity levels of the virtually the
worst of all our competitors and it just
doesn't seem to have any signs of that
getting any better so we just need a
push to get our public services the
problem that the Chancellor has though
is that he's got no money I mean the
deficit this year is going to be 56
billion pounds the interest on the
national debt this year is 48 billion
pounds it's the same as the defense
budget I mean there is just no money to
spend is there
yes but lots of the money that the
government is spending going on day to
day spending so the borrowing for day to
day spending that that doesn't create
any productivity or investment what
we've got to do is that yes we've got to
have spending on day to day stuff to get
the datastage services to get our public
services into a better shape but we've
also got to spend productively and
proactively on our infrastructure
whether that be railways and would that
be roads whether that be the digital
infrastructure and we've got to push on
that one and the housing crisis is that
has been discussed as well so you want
to see a big rise in public borrowing
how much we've set aside not on the date
of a spending so let's be absolutely
clear what we set aside is that we are
not going to borrow for day-to-day
expenditure in relation to our national
transformation plan over a 10-year
period the plan would be to borrow 250
billion that's about 50 billion pounds a
year of that 10-year period and also
emotional investment bank which would
leave early and about 250 billion from
the private sector and the private
sector want consistency they want the
ability to help us to grow the economy
and that's what our plans will be doing
and they are based on the conversations
and discussions that we have had with
business including organizations now
when private sector companies invest
they look for a return on capital 250
billion pounds is a huge sum of money
what sort of return you looking for on
that in
vestment well there would be let's take
an example there would be significant
rises in productivity with 35% behind
for example the Germans in terms of
productivity if we were able to close
that gap even by half or quite
significantly the growth in the economy
would be significant and indeed the
growth in tax revenues as a result of
that would be significant that's where
you're able to pay for the investment
but you're also urging the government to
lift the public sector pay cap I mean
that comes out of day to day spending so
essentially you are going to be
borrowing more unless you're going to
fund that from higher taxation well
that's right we have to keep the capital
investments separate from the day to day
expenditure what we've said in our
funding Britain's future plan which we
released in the general election and is
there for everyone to say we call it the
grade book that set aside forty eight
point six billion pounds of young
revenue or current spending and that's
matched by where we would raise that in
relation to taxes so for example over
the next five years the government's are
giving tax cuts to corporations of
seventy six billion pounds we believe
that that's not necessary
and that's would form part of our
spending our tax rises for corporations
and no tax increases for the bottom or
four ninety five percent of the
population so how much would corporation
tax go up by corporation tax would go
back to where it was at twenty six
percent which would still still leave us
competitive with with Germany France
they'd still be lower than Germany
France the United States and all our
major competitors the top one percent
already pay 30 percent of all taxes is
it really fair to pile even more taxes
on them well it is about fairness and
the bottom line is is that top one
percent of their wealth has grown
significantly over the past five six
seven years how do you think people
those people are going to react to this
I mean you're going to have to introduce
capital controls to stop these people
taking their money out of the country to
stop you taxing it
couple of controls and I think it's
another one of those figments of some
people's imagination that we would do no
we're not going to do yeah Rheda quote
to you this is from a column in The
Times this morning by Ian Martin and he
says here I love my home but I'm selling
it to prepare one of the country's
richest entrepreneurs told me recently
there will be capital controls I didn't
work that hard to hand it all over to
that thug MacDonald a lot of people who
think like that aren't there I don't
think a lot of people who think that at
all I think that's an incredibly crass
statement to make from a journalist or a
commentator in that particular newspaper
he has his axe to grind let him grind
the axe but we're getting on with the
job of trying to make this country
fairer and beneficial to everybody who
lives here not just the wealthiest